good morning second students today is
Friday calm day in Wildcat country and
these are your morning announcements
[Music]
describe it it's like magical like the
Grammys words I get butterflies in my
stomach so fashion show a competition
it's stressful I'm excited I'm just
ready to get it over with problems in
Flint are a very special thing I have a
black sparkly green and gold ball gown
it's real cutest elegant she picked out
a yellow shirt and a yellow and black
bowtie monday we like close friends he
actually came in the classroom with the
pizza box I know this may be cheesy but
will you be my prom date originally I
was hungover two girls but that didn't
work out
this problem is coming up it's really
special because it's the last part for
enough Western residents in shock
tonight after hearing of the potential
closing of another high school students
will no longer step in the plan or the
high school too close and there's only
going to be one high school in the city
plan lays off two hundred and six 238
teachers when schools facing a ten
million dollar million dollar deficit
I was thinking of maybe like cuz you
can't even see my shoes so I was like
maybe like some sandals cute this
morning I mean the big day is in a
couple of hours really
yeah something super nervous but I'm
really excited and how does it feel
knowing this is the school was last prom
ever and you'll be a part of it it feels
like I have it's like so much pressure I
had to go out with a bang you well she's
wearing purple color of royalty so
she'll do great for now live in Burton
I'm Courtney lien with Fox 66 news for
years too long four years later four
years after decisions by politicians
poisoned their water the people of Flint
say the state hasn't kept its promise
the state says the water is clean enough
to end distribution of bottled water
winter will soon run out of water
bottles water that is these are the
people waiting in line for bottled water
and so are these people I still got it
in my water you don't trust him no the
city will stop handing out water one
supplies run out
[Music]
every time I go somewhere someone hits
me with a water truth we were told the
water crisis was over we still can see
like yellow colors and brown in our
water they still say it's safe to drink
it's really not safe to drink we don't
trust them the whole situation is a slap
in the face the water is a problem when
it's more to it than that
closing our schools taking away Jane
abandon houses on one block violence any
killing I'm just tell you like this
[Music]
sláinte always about security under
Steve
[Music]
[Music]
mommy will you just dabble oh I'm
looking she looks so pretty this is a
day huh it's like magical you have these
people who you see all year and then
dressing like casual clothing and then
they look like princesses or Queens and
it's just a transformation they just
want to have a day where you ain't gotta
worry about nothing
[Music]
Simo if we didn't get to go to prom he
was 17 he got murdered a lot of people
my family didn't get to like a prom so
I'm doing this for everybody in my
family it's our time to shine people are
fleeing on you know time side
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I feel like outsiders literally just see
the benefit I feel as if very outside of
it and they're not looking inside and
what you really are
because flaming the exact opposite I
want people to see us for who we are I
feel like Flint is literally one of us
and if you don't take a step in you will
never know
[Music]
[Music]